تستحضر الكاشا روح الأرض
وحلاوة الحياة ، فالخمور القوية المصنوعة
من قصب السكر في قلب مشروب
تشتهر البرازيل بكايبيرينها
مرة أخرى ، بدأنا في ساو باولو
وهي أن نرى ولاية ساو باولو وهي
واحدة من رواد  كاسيوس أوز
اليوم ثقافة ودخل
معظم سكان ساو باولو ،
يتعلق الأمر بقصب السكر إما سكر
للإيثانول أو كازا
في معمل تقطير فالنتي في بيرثا ،
هذا الأب والابن يقومان
بعمل الأجيال التي سبقتهم
جميلة  ملكة جمال الصغيرة أولاً كنت
أفعلها ، ثم عندما أنهى المدرسة ،
بدأ العمل لتعلم كيفية جعل الكازا
الآن يجعلها تقليدًا طويلاً من
البيجامات التعارف التي تحتوي على شقرا
تركيا لدينا هذه المزرعة لأكثر من
40 عامًا ورثنا هذا التقليد
من جدي الأكبر
وجدي مروا به منذ أن
انتقلنا إلى المدينة ، اشترينا مزرعة بالقرب
من المدينة لإنشاء معمل التقطير هنا واستمرنا حتى يومنا
هذا.  العملية صغيرة بقدر ما
تأتي مع موظفين اثنين فقط ،
يتم حصاد قصب السكر
بالطريقة التقليدية المقطعة يدويًا أنطونيو الغرينية
Waukesha Chihuahua
اليوم ما يجعل Casa جيدًا هو
كل شيء من الخبرة والتقاليد
التي تنتقل من الأب إلى الابن
وأيضًا  جودة الإنتاج
الطبيعي العضوي ، يجب أن يتم
تصنيعه يدويًا للحصول على أفضل جودة ،
ثم يتم طحن القصب والعصير الذي
يتم استخراجه حيث يمر بعد ذلك
بعملية التقطير من هناك في
براميل البلوط التي كانت موجودة في الأسرة
منذ ما يقرب من  قرن